how are you doing today sir
i'm good steve how are you man i'm doing
excellent i am a big fan of your work
and it is great to talk with you today
cool thank you steve
not many people can be in both marvel
and dc
and you have won that lottery uh have
you thought about playing
like actual lottery scratch cards or
doing something because clearly
you know you've won the lottery yeah
well like you know i guess says yeah you
know since i already
i already won i i don't have to scratch
too many more i don't want to blow it
you know
uh it's uh yeah it's
you know if they're gonna tell these
stories i'll i'll gladly be a part of uh
helping to tell them um
what i what i appreciate i think
maybe most about these stories is how
passionate fans are
um about them you know i've been a part
of some big
franchises but the marvel
uh franchise um you know
the batman franchise there's just
another
uh level of amped that comes along with
being a part of these
um um these projects and i started to
ask myself
why that was why people are so um
so involved in and so opinionated about
who plays these roles and why are they
so
why do they have such a sense of
ownership over them
and i and i've and i've come to the
conclusion that because these are
stories about heroism
and because this there's this mythology
to these stories beyond you know the
dynamics of the
storytelling and the action and all of
that that mythology
is um so um deeply human
in some ways that i think they become a
place for
trust in a world that's becoming
increasingly untrustworthy
and that fans um find hope
in in in these in these characters and
in these narratives
in a way that perhaps they don't find
consistently
elsewhere and so the actors that play
those role
roles become caretakers of that hope in
some way and so the the
you know the the fans are looking and
say hey
don't don't mess with my stuff
you know take care of my stuff and so
there's a responsibility to it
um that that uh that you have to take
seriously and so i'm you know
i i really i really dig
being a part of it and i really uh and i
respect i respect people's passion for
it
so you hit the nail on the head actually
uh when you when you met with marvel to
talk about playing this role
did anyone ever like lay out a here's
what we're thinking for the future
here's this this and how and how much is
it sort of like
well you just it's just here's what if
we're not really sure what's gonna
happen after that
um well
um i you know i i take it
step by step and i i love doing voice
work
for one i love playing my voice
you know as a you know a musician my
play
uh an instrument and so i'm always
looking for cool you know animated stuff
to do voice stuff to do i just enjoy it
um and so yeah they
we've you know we've actually begun to
work on season two of this
and and then of course i think people
have
in their minds you know what else might
come
from this and i don't know anything is
possible
we'll see the thing that i like to say
though is the watcher has
always always there the watcher is in
every
uh marvel movie uh
he's always there observing um
and he's he's he's seen he's seen the
movies that have
haven't even been released yet so really
yeah i mean he's the watcher is the
watcher is
uh is is maybe
and there are some incredibly passionate
fans as i've described but he may be the
most passionate of all marvel fans
he's seen it all and we'll see it all
uh i am curious when you are recording
do they tell you the arc of every
episode do they give you all these
details or is it sort of like
you're just learning about what you're
really saying no i get
you know we have i get the full scripts
and um
and so i see the you know the full arc
um what i um
what i don't always know is i don't know
always know the implications
of of the um the twists that you know
we're considering
so i'll have to uh you know refer to
the writers and the producers sometimes
um or to my son
who could tell me the implications um
um in in in in in more
um in more detail than i might uh see
it you know on first read but no we yeah
i get the full
we we get the full uh i get the full
picture before him before i'm doing it
uh i saw the first three episodes and
they're great and i
i do enjoy seeing the watcher in the sky
when you
are not expecting to see him have you
have you have you seen the episodes
yes i have yeah what what's your take
away from the episodes versus what you
thought going in
versus uh how they actually turned out
oh that's a it's a good question because
there is a kind of disconnected quality
to doing animation
um there are some
basic um animated um
uh scenes that i may see
but never the full um you know the full
animatronics never we never see
anything like that um
and so i'm just putting my voice in i
may hear
something of what someone else has done
or i may not so it's a very piece meal
and so to see it all come together and
to understand
the full vision uh realized is
always uh is always a treat and
and um and it's gratifying when it works
so i think in this case um it works
uh and you never know until you
until you see it and you know in full um
you know in the in the flesh as it were
and that's always uh that's exciting but
it starts off it starts off in a more in
a much more disconnected way
i am a big fan of westworld um i have to
ask you where are you in the filming
process
of this upcoming season uh we're a few
episodes in
now um and
we have a few episodes to go yeah i'm
off
i'm off for a couple of days this week
but then uh
we get back into it we're doing some fun
stuff as always
i was gonna say last season was a lot
different than i think
people expected it took some awesome um
uh paths i'm not sure how i can describe
that i'm butchering it but i guess how
does this upcoming season compare to
last season
and what came before if you don't mind
uh this season is
you know every year um we started off
season one
westworld and then season two it gets
squared
and then season three it's cubed
you know season four is you know let's
world to the fourth power you know it
just it just it just continues to
you know the onion just continues to uh
to unfold and then uh to kind of
um uh split and diffract and
you know it's just ongoing man it's it's
it's uh
it it's it's it's never um
it's it's never something that i can
kind of get in front of and anticipate
it's always moving in directions that
are unexpected and um
and and and sensible but really
um surprising so i just i
i love i love the ride that we're on
completely i have to stop there
again congratulations on being part of
what if can't wait to see the rest of
the episodes have a fantastic day
cool thanks steve